[موسيقى]
تصدرها مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
في العالم الافتراضي من خلال مقاطع
لتقديم العوني
عباس يعني صار لك بهذا السوق صار الهوايه
يعني هو من مواليد 81
يعني هو يعني بالتسعينات يلتقي عباس
قمت اشوف عباس دائما يفوت منه انا من
السوق اشوف العامل السيء للتعامله يعني
عباس ما يخليه يطلب المحل عباس
شفت عباس انا عباس يعني شفت شكله شيء
حبيته
[موسيقى]
من البشر
الصغير كما لقب في العراق
ماشي
قلبك
[موسيقى]
الثاني
فتفاعل معه الجمهور حتى ان قوات البيشمركه
في كردستان العراق اطلقت مبادره لمساعدته
واخر المتفاعلين كان وزاره الصحه العراقيه
متعهدتا لمتابعه حالته الصحيه
ان شاء الله راح نكملها من فرشه
ومن شربايه ان شاء الله
يعيش عباس مع جدته وجده في بيت بسيط
ويتعايش كليا مع حالته ويقضي يومه كاين
منا ويصب جل اعماله بغير صديقه الوحيد
الذي اعطاه والاخر درسا عن التعاون والحب
من دون مقابل لسكان عالمي لترند
[موسيقى]